[Music]
[Applause]
I have a very special surprise guest
here tonight and I am so excited to chat
with him please welcome actor and TV
icon Kadeem Hardison
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me
I'm gonna be honest I'm a huge fan a
different world was one of my all-time
favorite shows there's two okay that
goes for everybody and your portrayal of
character Dwayne Wayne was
groundbreaking for introducing America
to a young HBCU student who was smart
and cool
what was it like to portray such an
iconic character oh well thank you Amber
um it was an honor you know one of my
favorite things when strangers
approached me out in the wild to tell me
if they've been inspired by my work I
love that that's what it's all about
that's
is nothing better okay can I say
something
who said that it was me sorry to
interrupt but I'm a huge fan and I just
had to take the opportunity to tell
Kadeem how much he inspired me oh thank
you uh your work on a different world
showed me it was actually cool to be
smart because of you I stayed in school
worked hard and became a cardiovascular
surgeon
[Music]
thank you Kadeem you inspired me wow
your story of sticking it out and
pushing
suing your goals until you achieve them
that's the real headline here young lady
the honor is all mine I
[Applause]
know oh my God
ah thank you Mr Hardison and Amber you
inspired me too oh really yes your work
in that sketch goldfish who smells her
own farts underwater it showed me that
sometimes it's okay to be disgusted plus
it was the first time I had ever seen a
black woman fart on TV
thank you you inspired me
right
right that's great thank you for
speaking up I'm glad I could help all
right now we're moving on I I also have
something I'd like to say that's not
really how this works
Kadeem as a young man I had a love for
algebra but was embarrassed because I
didn't want the other kids at school to
call me a nerd that is until Dwayne
Wayne came along and showed me how
someone can be good at math and still
pull fly honeys
now I'm a nuclear physicist with a
beautiful wife and a family of my own
all thanks to you you inspired me
[Music]
a nuclear physicist wow I'm an actor you
know uh the dramatic arts of my craft
but no matter the yarn I spend it could
never shed light on the enigmatic
subatomic life of a quark
thank you for your work you're the real
inspiration here my man
and Amber you inspired me too I did yeah
all my life I've been afraid to sing in
public but then I heard you sing a song
on this show that was so
off-key and
so offbeaten just so bad
I couldn't believe peacock didn't force
the editors to dub it over in post
it was like you were trying to miss
every note get to the point
you inspired me to never be afraid to
let the world hear my voice so hey hey
[Music]
okay you're welcome sir moving on
I just want wait um I also have
something I'd like to say why is
their member miked
Kadeem your work on a different world
was Fearless the show never stood away
from heavy subject matter like racism
the AIDS epidemic or domestic violence
in fact watching you tackle those tough
issues inspired me to achieve my own
dream of becoming an investigative
journalist for the New York Times
[Applause]
[Music]
ah from the bottom of my heart thank you
oh thank you oh uh amber your head is so
very big
dang it will you people just let me
interview this man I love him I brought
him here so I could get to know him and
make him be my little friend now shut up
I'm sorry about that Kadeem now I have a
question for you oh okay what do you do
that brings you Joy
actually
watching the Amber Ruffin show brings me
joy yeah yes absolutely in these dark
times your blend of lighthearted humor
and hard-hitting historical analysis
has been exactly the thing we need to
get us through this pandemic
your comedy is an inspiration and it
begs everyone in America to tell the
truth
oh my God thank you Denise that is so
nice thank you oh thank you because you
inspired me to tell the truth and the
truth is you got a big old head
like it's like a boulder how you walk
with his head
you can't give up because then everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]